[Music]
after numerous speculations last week it
is now official
disney is again postponing a large
number of films the year 2020 will thus
be the first year since 2009 in which
not a single mcu film is released
especially black widow with scarlett
johansson in the leading role as
affected
since originally the marvel blockbuster
was supposed to be released in may of
this year before it was postponed to
november and then finally to may 7th
2021
however the first phase iv film is not
the only one of its kind to receive a
delayed release
as shang shi and the legend of the ten
rings is also postponed until july 9th
2021 and the eternals to november 5th
2021.
nevertheless fans of the marvel
cinematic universe won't have to abstain
completely from new content
because as you can see in a recently
released trailer the series one division
still awaits us this year on disney plus
in addition to the marvel adventures
other disney films have received new
release dates
including the empty man which will now
be released on october 23rd this year
and the king's man
the beginning which has a new start date
of february 12 2021.
steven spielberg's new adaptation of
west side story was particularly
affected as it was surprisingly
rescheduled by a whole year to december
10th 2021 as you can see
there is a lot going on regarding film
postponements and we can only hope that
the new start dates will not be put in
question in the near future
in december the time has finally come
the top class science fiction epic dune
will be released in the past few weeks
we have already had a glimpse of the
giant sand worms and the etrades family
now the villain baron harkonnen has been
unveiled the whole thing however was not
revealed at all by secret pictures from
the set or leaked film clips
but by a dune action figure which will
be available in the usa in autumn
until now the baron was only seen hidden
in wafts of mist and mud baths
but now we can take a first look at the
villain's outfit fans of the previous
film adaptations already know that baron
harkonnen is distinguished above all by
his incredibly massive stature
in fact he is so massive that he needs a
floating spacesuit to move around
and it's exactly this suit that the toy
now shows us as director denis valenov
told variety fair the baron is said to
be much more frightening in the new
interpretation than in previous ones
which were always presented in a rather
ridiculous way due to their fullness
of body felony emphasized that he did
not want the baron to degenerate into a
caricature which is why actor stellan
skarsgard and his terrifying appearance
fit the role of the baron perfectly we
hope that we will soon be able to
present you with real footage of baron
harkonnen and are very excited about the
expected release of dune
on 12 18 20 20.
so far the production of fantastic
beasts 3 was not really blessed with
luck
first the start of shooting was
postponed twice and then johnny depp's
trial against ex-wife amber heard also
occurred
as lead actor eddie redmayne has now
revealed in an interview with cinnamon
blend the shooting has been going on for
two weeks
of course not without masks and regular
tests the forced break however
is supposed to have done no harm to the
motivation on set because according to
redmayne
everyone is doing their best something
else that is also beneficial is the
postponement of johnny depp's trial
after all a renunciation of the actor
would probably not have been an option
as deadline magazine reports the 57 year
old's role is quite big which is why
he's needed on set from october to
february
good news for everyone involved
fantastic beasts 3 is scheduled to be
released on november 12
2021 after a long break
the upcoming lord of the rings amazon
series is back on track
it has been known for quite some time
that the production is going to be a
huge spectacle right from the beginning
but galadriel actress morphith clark
recently revealed in an interview with
nme
how extensive and detailed the work is
actually done on set according to her
own statement
she was very overwhelmed by the massive
production for example
one of the employees is supposed to have
the mundane task of monitoring how the
dust reacts to the actor's steps and
breath
she herself had never thought that such
a thing even existed and could only
imagine similar perfectionist work on a
marvel
set another point she finds very
interesting is the return of well-known
actors from the film trilogy
she is especially looking forward to the
idea of elijah wood's return and
actually every old star should at least
get a cameo appearance but the one who
is dropping out at his own request is
elrond actor hugo weaving he was very
happy to return to the set for the
shooting of the hobbit trilogy
but at the same time he believes that
everyone has had enough of the franchise
by now and we agree with him on at least
one point
a conclusive return of old actors
without any real use for the content
seems very unnatural
anyway we are looking forward to further
news about the lord of the rings amazon
series
the release could be at the end of 2021
at the earliest
with a recent tweet wrestler and actor
john cena announces a new film about his
character peacemaker from the upcoming
the suicide squad film the project will
feature eight episodes and will be a
mixture of action
adventure and comedy none other than the
suicide squad creator james gunn is
responsible for the script
and the 54 year old will also be
involved in directing some episodes
as it is often the case there are still
very few details known about the series
at the moment but in this specific case
this will probably have to be related to
the fact that the suicide squad hasn't
even been released in the cinema yet
besides gotham pd
peacemaker would be the second hbo max
series from dc
and it can be assumed that the dc
universe will be significantly expanded
in the future on hbo max
the shooting of peacemaker is expected
to start early next year which makes a
release at the end of 2021 seem quite
[Music]
realistic
[Music]